محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين اما
بعد يقول
تعالى واصفا
نفسه عالم الغيب والشهاده الكبير
المتعال سواء منكم من اسر القول ومن جهر
به ومن هو مستخف بالليل وسارب
بالنهار له معقبات من بين يديه ومن خلفه
يحفظونه من امر
الله ان الله لا يغير ما بقوم حتى يغيروا
ما
بانفسهم واذا اراد الله بقوم سوء فلا مرد
له وما لهم من دونه من
وال قوله تعالى عالم الغيب
الغيب
مصدر مصدر غاب يغيب
غيبا
والمقصود
عالم ما
يغيب على
الناس عالم الغائب على الناس اسم
الفاعل الا ان الله تعالى وصف اسم
فاعل
بالمصدر هذا يدل على ماذا على
المبالغه واذا علمنا وفهمنا
هذا عرفنا ان الغيب
غيبان غيب
نسبي وغيب
مطلق الغيب النسبي ما كان يغيب على بعض
دون بعض يعني هو
غيب بالنسبه الى زمن او مكان او انسان
معين هذا اسمه غيب نسبي يعني مثلا ما في
نفسك غيب بالنسبه
لي وما في
نفسي غيب بالنسبه
لك لكن هل هو غيب مطلق يخفى علينا جميعا
لا س
لنا للتوصل اليه الجواب
لا هذا اسمه غيب
النسبي والله عز وجل يعلم
ذلك لكن ليس هذا هو المقصود
بالغيب لماذا
للمبالغه هذه المبالغه مهمه الذين يؤمنون
بالغيب يعني يؤمنون بما لا سبيل لل توصل
اليه من
العلوم لماذا يؤمنون لان رسول الله اخبرهم
بس هذا هو السبب فهم
يؤمنون يؤمنون بماذا يؤمنون بالجنه والنار
والاخره
والبعث يؤمنون
ب الرسالات السابقه
وهلم جره القدر
هذا اسمه غيب واما الغائب فهذا
دونه
ف لاحظوا مثلا هذا الاسلوب
العربي الحديث حديث معروف لدى الكثير عند
مسلم من حديث زينب ام المؤمنين رضي الله
عنها ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قام
فزعا محمرا
وجهه فقال ويل للعرب من شر قد
اقترب على كل حال وساق الحديث الامام مسلم
الى نهايه الحديث
سالت زينب قالت يا رسول الله انهلك وفينا
الصالحون قال نعم اذا كثر
الخبث
ايش
الخبل هذا اسمه وصف
بالمصدر يعني الخبثاء
اذا
كثروا في المجتمع المسلم
الطيب فان هؤلاء يفسدون
المجتمع فاذا كثر
الخبث مش بس الخبث لا
الخبث
ثء حتى
يفسدوا طبع المجتمع
ويفسدوا فطره المجتمع هنالك ياتي العذاب
نسال الله
العافيه هذا اسلوب عربي معروف الصف
بالمصدر تقول
مثلا
فلان
حكم
عدل يعني واحد عادل في عندك العادل وعندك
ايش
العدل العدل هذا يعني وصف
بالمصدر فعلى كل حال قوله تعالى عالم
الغيب هذا يرفع عنا الاشكال لماذا احنا
ندخل في هذه المساله يرفع عنا الاشكال
لانه بعض الناس يسال
اسئله السؤال نفسه يدل على الفهم
الخاطئ فيقول لك
مثلا الله تعالى يعلم ما في الارحام طيب
ونحن الان نعلم ما في الارحام هذا يدل على
جهل في اللغه العربيه
تمام
جاهل كبير في
اللغه يعلم ما في الارحام ما هنا يعني كل
شيء في
الرحم من لحظه ان يكون
الشيء شيئا في الرحم يعلمه سبحانه وتعالى
هل نحن نعلم
ذلك ما في الارحام ما قال يعلم اذا كان
ذكرا ام
انثى اذا كان معاقا ام صحيحا ما قال هذا
قال يعلم ما في الارحام كل شيء
من لحظه ان يكون الشيء شيئا في الرحم
يعلمه الله سبحانه وتعالى وقبل
ذلك لكن العلم بكون الشيء حدث اختلف عن
العلم بكون الشيء
سيحدث فقوله تعالى عالم الغيب هذا الشيء
يختص بهذا الوصف الله سبحانه وتعالى هو
عالم الغيب
واما غيره سبحانه فقد يكون عالم
غيبا
ممكن لذلك ياتي في
الحديث الحديث الذي رواه الامام البخاري
من حديث ابن
عمر ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
مفاتيح الغيب
خمس
قال لا يعلم ما في غد الا
الله ولا
يعلم ما في الارحام الا الله ولا يعلم متى
ياتي المطر الا الله ولا تدري نفس باي ارض
تموت ولا يعلم متى تقوم الساعه الا الله
هكذا في
الحديث هذه ايش م فاتيح
الغيب قال تعالى
وعنده مفاتح
الغيب وفي قراءه سبعيه
متواتره وعنده مفاتيح
الغيب لا يعلمها الا هو مفاتيح الغيب ايش
يعني مفاتيح جمع
مفتاح و ذلك بدايات ونهايات الغيب كلها
معلومه لله هذا وصف يختص الله سبحانه
وتعالى
به فقوله صلى الله عليه
وسلم ولا ي ولا يعلم
متى ياتي المطر الا الله مش الان عننا
احنا اجهزه تنظر في سماء وستلايت
و مش عارف ايش من التكنولوجيا وقول لك
بدها تمطر بدهاش تمطر يقول لك بدها تبقى
حر سكعه برد نقول هذه
ماذا هذه من
الغيب من الغيب النسبي ولا
المطلق
النسبي هذا من الغيب
النسبي يعني مثلا السحابه تلع وتيجي
من المرب
م كان وغربه مطرت عليه صح ولا لا مطرت
عليه وخلصت هو
عرف ان هذه السحابه فيها مطر قبلنا ولا لا
هذا غيب
نسبي الذي ينظر بالكاميرات او ينظر مثلا
في الرحم يضع الجهاز ويعلم هذه اشياء
ضئيله جدا لا تدل على شيء ولا يختص علم
الله سبحانه وتعالى بمجرد ماذا بمجرد هل
الجنين ذكر ام انثى هذا شيء ولا ولا يتبدى
هذا لنا الا بعد مده بعد
حين ويخطئون ايضا في
ذلك لان مبناه غلبه الظن
كذلك هل الجهاز في جهاز في الدنيا بقول لك
هذا الجنين راح يطلع صاح هذا
الجنين راح
يطلع انسان صالح او طالح او شرير او عفريت
او شيطان او هذا بده يكون ذو خلق حسن او
من العلماء او هذا يكون من
المجرمين
هذا يختص الله تعالى
به جاء في روايه ابن
مسعود عند الامام
مسلم يقول عبد الله بن مسعود رضي الله
عنه واصل الحديث في
الصحيحين
يقول
حدثنا حدثنا رسول الله وهو الصادق مصدوق
ان
احدكم يجمع خلقه في بطن امه 40 يو نطفه ثم
يكون علقه مثل ذلك ثم يكون مضغه مثل ذلك
ثم يرسل اليه الملك ويؤمر بنفخ الروح
ويؤمر بكتب
اربع
ماله
بكتب اجله وعمله ورزقه وشقي او
سعيد في زياده عند الامام مسلم برضه من
حديث عبد
الله ان الملك حينما يبعث الى الجنين
فيقول اي ربي اشقي ام سعيد اي ربي اذكر ام
انثى اي ربي اي يعني يا
ربي ما رزقه اي ربي ما اجله
فيملي عليه الله سبحانه وتعالى والملك
يكتب هذا هو الغيب هذا شيء يختص به ربنا
سبحانه
وتعالى لذلك
قال لا يظهر على
غيبه ايش يعني غيبه الغيب الذي هو لله
يختص الله
به
هذه اشياء ليش الصحابه ما سالوا هذه
الاسئله ليش احنا عندنا اسئله
نسالها ليش
الصحابه ما خطر على بالهم يسالوا هذه
الاسئله الجواب لانها ليست اشكاليات عندهم
لانهم يفهمون اللغه
العربيه احنا بسبب العجمه اللي دخلت علينا
وطرت على السنه
وزد على ذلك الاستعمار
والسفر الى بلاد والثقافات والاندماج في
الثقافات التي هي ليست
ثقافات مسها الاسلام فضلا عن ان تكون
مسلمه طرا علينا هذه
الافكار هذه الافكار طرات علينا وعلى
بالنا وتعبتنا واحن بنبحث عنها وبعض الناس
يسال ويظن انه سؤال يعني
سؤال ما خطر على بال حدا سؤال يعني تفرد
هو به ما في حدا عنده فطنه زيه يعني خطر ع
باله هذا السؤال من قبل مثلا ياتيك احد
الناس ويقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول ياتيه منكر ونكير فيجلسانه فيساله
طيب يا شيخ كيف يجلسه واصلا هو في القبر
وما في وساع انه يجلس كانه يعني كانه
الزلمه مفكر متدبر ما ح يعني تدبر هذه
الاشياء من
قبل هذا يدل على
ماي
في في
الفهم على كل
حال يقول تعالى عالم الغيب والشهاده
يعني ما يشاهده الناس
الشاهد يعني الظاهر
للناس الكبير
المتعال الكبير من اسماء الله تعالى
الكبير الذي يصغر كل شيء
دونه سبحانه وتعالى خير ما قيل في تفسير
اسم
الكبير الذي يصغر كل شيء
دونه لا اله الا الله الكبير
المتعال من اسماء الله
العلي العلي
هنا واسم اخر
المتعال المتعال يعني
المتعالي وهذا ايضا من
الاسلوب العرب عند الوقف
يحذفون حرف
العله اذا كانت ياء نسبه او اذا كانت
ياء يعني مثلا يا متكلم يقول ربي
وربي كلاهما صحيح نفس
المعنى وما خلقت الجن والانس الا
ليعبدون
ليعبدوني نفس الشيء نفس
المعنى وه
المتعال
وق وراءه سبعيه متواتره
المتعالي الله سبحانه وتعالى من اسمائه
العلي ومن اسمائه المتعالي
المتعالي يعني يدل على هو اسم اسم اسم
فاعل من
التعالي فهو اسم فاعل المتعالي يعني يدل
على
الاستمرار يعني انه لا يزال يتعالى على كل
شيء
يعلو
المتعالي والله تعالى يقول سواء منكم سواء
يعني نفس الشيء
يستوي سواء
منكم من اسر القول ومن جهر
به يعني الذي يجهر
والذي يسر القول
ويضمر يقول ومن هو مستخف
بالليل الذي يتخفى في الليل
ومن هو سارب بالنهار يعني ومن هو ماشي في
الطريق في رابعه
النهار سواء منكم هذول كلهم سواء عند الله
سبحانه وتعالى احنا نشوف الفرق الله
سبحانه وتعالى ليس ثم
فرق له سبحانه وتعالى في نظره ولا في سمعه
ولا في بصره ولا في علمه ولا في احاطته
ولا في معيته ما في فرق ابدا بين
هذه متضادات
فانه سبحانه وتعالى لا يخفى عليه لا تخفى
عليه
خافيه يعلم السر واخفى يعني واخفى من
السر فهو سبحانه وتعالى يخبرنا انه
سواء منا يعني ما يصدر
منا من اسر
القول ومن جهر به ومن هو مستخف
بالليل وسارب بالنهار
السار اما انه ماخوذ من السرب السرب اللي
هو
الطريق يقال هذا سرب يعني هذا
طريق
او من السرب والسرب هو
المشي اخذ الطريق والذهاب والاياب في
الحاجه فهو يقول سبحانه وسارب بالنهار
يعني الذي يطلب الظهور اقصى الظهور
واقصى الخفاء سواء عنده سبحانه
وتعالى يقول له معق بات من بين يديه ومن
خلفه يحفظونه من امر
الله له
معقبات
له الء
هذه اختلف العلماء الضمير عائد على من
له هل المقصود له يعني
للانسان
معقبات وقال بعض
له يعني
لله
معقبات المعنى يؤدي الى نفس المعنى
لكن اذا
خليناها لله معقبات من بين
يديه صار في يعني ارتباك صار في ركاكه في
اللفظ لذلك رجح
العلماء له يعني
للانسان
معقبات
اي
ملائكه يعقب بعضهم
بعضا ملائكه في النهار وملائكه في
الليل هؤلاء
معقبات واجمع السلف يعني
الصحابه على معنى معقبات بمعنى ملائكه
الملائكه سماهم الله تعالى
معقبات يعقب بعضهم
بعضا ملائكه بالليل وملائكه
بالنهار لاحظوا معي هذه
القصه الله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول له معقبات من من بين يديه ومن
خلفه له ملائكه من امامه ملائكه من خلفه
يعقب بعضهم بعضا يعني في النهار وفي الليل
اثنين في النهار واثنين في الليل في سوره
قاف ماذا يقول اذ اذ يتلقى المتلقيان عن
اليمين وعن
الشمالي فهذ هذان ملكان عن يمين
والشمال والله عز وجل
وصفهما
ب الع العتاد بمعنى ان هذه الملائكه او
هؤلاء الملائكه معتادون دائما ما يغيبوا
ابدا فقال
عتيد فالان الانسان كل
واحد عنده ا ملائكه واحد امامه و واححد من
خلفه في الليل والنهار صاروا كم
اربعه وعن اليمين والشمال واحد يكتب
الحسنات واحد يكتب السيئات مش بس هيك اللي
على اليمين يكتب الحسنات ويامر بالخير
واللي على الشمال يكتب السيئات وينهى عن
الشر عن
المنكر
ف واحد عن اليمين واحد عن الشمال في
الصباح وفي المساء صاروا كم
ثمانيه كل واحد عنده اقل احواله اقل
احواله
ثمان ملائكه معه هذول من ساعه ولادته الى
ان يتوفاه
الله غير الملك اللي بيجي بينفخ فيه الروح
غير الملائكه اللي بتيجي بتحضر عشان الموت
غير ملك الموت اللي بيجي بيسحب الروح غير
الملك اللي بطلعه على السماء غير الملك
اللي كل هذا كل انسان انظروا
الى انظروا الى هذه العنايه
العظيمه
للانسان والله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول ايحسب الانسان ان يترك سدى كل هذا
عشان
بس الفاضي
يعني الله سبحانه وتعالى جعل كل هذا
التوازن وكل هذا العلم وكل هذه الحياه وكل
هذه الامور التي تحيط
بالانسان من اجل ماذا ايش يكون النتيجه
لذلك لما تسال لماذا
يكره الله
اللغو يقول تعالى والذين هم عن اللغو
معرضون ايش اللغو ما لا فائده
منه يا في الدنيا في الاخره ما منه فائده
هو مش حرام
اللغو الحرام له اسم ثاني هو بس لغو يعني
ما ما في
فائده الله سبحانه وتعالى وصف
احباء احبائه
سبحانه
عباده عباد الرحمن
وصفهم بانهم عن اللغو معرضون اصحاب
الفردوس
لماذا لان اللغو يجعل كل هذه العنايه على
ايش وكانها على
الفاضي كانها يعني لا شيء كلها الملائكه
وكلها العنايه وكل هذا
يكتب وهذا يامر وهذا يفعل عشان النتيجه
تكون
ماذا الانسان يعني يضيع
الوقت
لذلك
المبذرين كانوا من اخوان
الشياطين على كل حال
نكمل الى هنا ان شاء الله نكتفي بهذا
القدر والله اعلم صلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد 10 ver سه
الر الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وت
destion first is
the of that which is
سبحانه
وتعالى ز
الكبير
سم
best one the
best
given الله الكبير
الكبير الله الكبير means the one all
el
small
all
المتعال
الي
الله
المتعال that
arat above and be and in far he
over all
that
سبحانه
وتعالى those of you who are silent keep
to
themselves their
silence or those of you who speak
plainly
those
the
‏and
are and in
day me الله سبحانه
وتالى does
not
experience the any difficulty in
distinguishing our actions our
spe ‏whether our speech is something
that we keep to ourselves or whisper or
whether
we the mountain the
hs and equ to are those of us who are
hiden in the midle dep of the
night and those who are plainly public
in
day الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏public سبحانه
وتالى الله سبحانه
وتالى human
not
الله
also الله makes things to other
creation
he that
human
مع مع mean there are
angels
that over every human being in
shi in shs
المعق
mean angs take shs over the
human صلى الله عليه
وسلم have
angels on our right and on our left they
wr our good deeds the angel on
left any of our bad
‏and that these angels are in two
shifts we have the day time and the
night ang take
place which
عرج
so
use there more
wies الج
‏arriv
take so both sets
are here at the time as we pray likewise
for and so these
two these
two
‏most prayers why because one of the
reasons they
are most witness there are most more
witnesses to those prayers from amongst
the
angels and so these mu are not just the
angels of the right and the left these
mu are two different
angels they are angels which are in
front and ‏behind a
person that every person human being has
angels ahead of him and behind him they
spend their entire a person spends his
entire life with in the presence of
these angels you cannot see them but
they can see
you and they have been delegated the
task of watching over the human being
and protecting the human being
الله
الله so that only what has been for the
person to
will we
will والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد
[Silence]
ه